prosecutors in Guatemala are
investigating if the country's emergency
response agency was negligent in its
response to the country's deadly volcano
eruption authorities admit communication
errors delayed evacuations when the
Fuego volcano exploded last Sunday at
least 109 people were killed and nearly
200 are believed to be missing
Manuel Bojorquez is in a squint Lacroix
Tamala where dangerous weather
conditions are impacting recovery
operations many good morning good
morning one lawmaker told us it took
three hours after scientists issued an
evacuation warning for the country's
emergency management team to order one a
delay officials blame on a communication
breakdown one they believe may have cost
lives nearly five days after the initial
eruption volcan de fuego continues to
spew smoke and ash but despite the
danger and questions about the
government response father Martin Sudan
remains focused on acting as a source of
comfort to those whose future is now
uncertain at least 120 people have
sought refuge in his parish church like
the fina Alvarez Garcia and her children
where do you go now nowhere to go
Juana malas Office of Emergency
Management is now being criticized for
not acting fast enough Eddie Sanchez is
the head of Guatemala's Institute of
Volcanology Fame for moon he says the
people who were supposed to be informed
were informed
I'm not empowered to declare a state of
national emergency according to a
government official scientists issued
their first volcano alert around 6 a.m.
on Sunday another issued at 10:00 and
then another at 1:00 in the afternoon
urging evacuations more than three hours
later the country's Emergency Management
Agency issued an evacuation order but it
was only voluntary not damos we did not
act because at no time were we given
something that would allow us to make a
decision he said as for the injured on
Thursday six children were flown to
Galveston Texas where they're being
treated for severe burns what we have
put together from the stories as well as
they're looking at the wounds today in
the condition these were from the ash
clouds back in Guatemala
Medical
and more water has arrived for some but
the big question is what do they do
after where do they live there are
currently more than four thousand people
living in shelters this bad weather and
more eruptions forced officials to
suspend the search for bodies in
villages beyond this roadblock but some
determined family members said they
would go up there and do it themselves
Nora
Wow Manuel Bojorquez who's been doing
some incredible reporting from Guatemala
this week thank you